Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to this AACR 2026 Mini Symposium in Metabolic
Signaling and Therapeutic Vulnerabilities in Cancer.
My name is Itziar Bukey Martinez. I'm Assistant Professor in Fox Chase Cancer
Center in Philadelphia, and I have the pleasure to co-chair this
session with...
I'm Sam McBrayer, an Assistant Professor at the Children's Research
Institute at UT Southwestern.
So we have structured the mini symposium in three parts.
The first part, four speakers will take the podium,
and after each talk, we will open the mic for questions.
After that, Sam will introduce the next three speakers, and
same, we will open the floor for questions
after each talk. And if time allows, during the last 10 minutes,
we will start a discussion about all the topics, and we
hope that all of you want and will participate in the discussion.
Today's talks, we'll explore how metabolic signaling shapes
tumor behavior and reveals therapeutic
vulnerabilities from mechanistic insights to
emerging translational strategies.
Together,
they highlight how understanding cancer metabolism can point us toward new,
more effective treatment schedules and options.
So it's my pleasure to introduce our first
speaker. It's Dr. Khalil Abdullah.
Where is he? Ah, here it is.
So Dr. Khalil is Associate Professor and Director of Translational
Neuro-Oncology from the University of Pittsburgh Medical Center, and he's going to
present his project, "A Targetable Metabolite Increases Neuronal
Hyperexcitability in a Glioma Microenvironment and Directs
Tumor Growth."
Thank you very much. Thanks for having me.
I'm excited to talk about the work we've been doing over the past couple of years
identifying a targetable metabolite that increases
neuronal activity and thus excitability in the glioma
microenvironment, and we believe drives tumor growth.
So we started with a bigger question.
What metabolite signaling could drive high-grade gliomas that's
independent of IDH mutations, independent of grade,
and mutational status? And we did that by collecting
91 neurosurgical samples in a row, prospectively.
And this was the idea that we could grab high-grade gliomas,
low-grade gliomas,
metastases, and normal brain, and be able to run a multi-omics approach, but
focusing on unbiased metabolomics.
And we evaluated 563 different metabolites, and
of those,
the one that was most remarkable and most overabundant was guanosine
acetate, and I'm going to refer to that as GAA throughout the talk.
And
this is an intermediate in the creatine synthesis pathway.
So as we looked at it, the first question is always, is this
a function of cell turnover? These gliomas are very busy.
Are they just creating lots of cellular architecture?
But if you look at these peak intensities, you'll see that GAA was increased
relative to high-grade glioma, low-grade glioma, and brain, while
creatine, phosphocreatine, and creatinine were all
mostly the same, indicating that this was accumulation that was
differential from the pathway.
And that as we continued to work through this, we validated this with two
additional independent cohorts.
And then if you look at the ability to discriminate between tissues on the
basis of GAA, you can see that GAA
is increased in high-grade glioma versus brain, and then again in high-grade
glioma versus low-grade glioma with true positive rates that are
quite high. We took an approach towards stable
isotope tracing here, which helped us identify this was truly
a bottleneck, and you can see here that in TS516
glioma stem cells, in comparison to NHAs, you have contributions of fractional
enrichment of
GAA, but not creatine. And that as you accumulate
GAA, this appears to be driven by an imbalance in AGAT and
GAMT, which is highly correlated to glioma grade, and
AGAT being upstream and GAMT being downstream of
GAA.
We looked at this in vitro, and in vitro, you can see there's a variety of cell
lines, both IDH mutant glioma stem cells and IDH wild-type glioma stem
cells. All of them have variable
secretion of GAA into the media, but it's very
clear that
neural stem cells and normal human astrocytes do not.
We also looked at a neurosurgical approach and tried to use our
ability to spatially evaluate these lesions
and actually generated organoids from neurosurgical resections, and
you can see the stereotactic images here.
But basically, we were able to demonstrate that these organoids
secreted GAA into the media
in a ratio that was quite high in comparison to normal brain.
And we further expanded that by looking at a series of cases where we could
spatially resolve
where high-grade glioma cells actually existed.
This is an IDH wild-type glioblastoma, but you can see that as you move
closer to the tumor from where the surgical corridor is at
entry, where there is normal cortex, the GAA
is quite low. And as you move towards the margin or the flare, you have an
increase in the number of tumor cells, and subsequently, you have an increase in
GAA, and you can move all the way to the tumor.
And all of this is the case with an increase in AGAT expression
and a stable
and non-significant difference in creatine.
A genetic knockout demonstrated that as you knock out AGAT, you
have an increase in overall survival of these mice.
There's an increase in tumor GAA in the wild type compared to the knockout,
and creatine, again, remains the same.
When you abolish AGAT,
GAA secretion is diminished, but that does not affect the cell fitness in
vitro. So these cells are just fine. They grow normally in a dish.
And foreshadowing a little bit to come, when you move these extracranially
outside of the neural environment, they don't have any difference in growth rate in
the subcutaneous flank.So what is the mechanism
by which this is happening, given that there seems to be a differential
effect of placing these cells in the brain versus in the systemic
parts of the body? Well, GAA is not a random metabolite in the
sense that there also is a correlate here.
GAMT deficiency is an inborn error of metabolism that's quite
rare. But when these patients present, what they present with is a
massive accumulation of GAA, but their symptoms are driven by
toxicity of GAA in the brain. So these patients
present with intractable epilepsy, hypotonia, neurologic dysfunction.
In some ways, they mirror the clinical presentation of patients with GBM.
And this is actually an EEG. These patients have seizures.
This is a patient who's seizing. And when you provide a GAA-lowering diet,
which we'll come to in a minute, you actually see normalization of that EEG.
And we know from a lot of our excellent collaborators, and partners in the field
that elevated neural activity is observed in glioma and
propagates growth. And we know from inborn errors of
metabolism that GAMT deficiency also has a
relationship with elevated GAA. So we looked back at our knockouts, and
we found that in these situations, GAA actually
reverses neuronal depletion, reverses neural
excitability in the glioma microenvironment.
And you can see here that there is an AGAT wild-type mouse in which
c-Fos, which is an indicator of neural activation,
is elevated in the peritumoral cortex and compared to the AGAT knockout.
Similarly, when looking at vGlut1, which is a marker
of neuron-glioma interaction, you see a substantial decrease, when
AGAT is knocked out in comparison to AGAT wild-type cells.
And you're going to have to hang with me here for a minute.
We're taking a bit of a turn into cancer neuroscience. I hope it makes sense.
I'm just a country neurosurgeon, so I try and move along with the flow.
But what you'll see is that GAA and GABA actually have a very
similar chemical structure. And there has been some work in the past that has
evaluated GAA and why it causes neural excitability and
epilepsy in patients who have GAMT deficiency.
And what we found was that in a correlation to
other studies,
GAA appears to act at the GABA A receptor.
So you can see here GAA is applied, and then
gabazine is applied, which abrogates the effect of
a
large GABA A receptor-dependent outward current, which we see in these normal
mouse hippocampal brain slices.
Now,
why is it that occurs? That seems to be a inhibitory
mechanism when applying GAA.
Well, in normal brain, that is a normal adult brain, chloride
efflux is hyperpolarizing. And in those situations, KCC2,
which modulates chloride, is actually normal.
But in the glioma environment, KCC2 is down, which
causes a chloride efflux, which is depolarizing.
And as it turns out, this was also at the same time,
work was being done by Michel Amanji's group, which demonstrated that in DMG, you
actually had GABA agonism, which causes tumor proliferation in
those patients. And so we've confirmed in our xenografts
that KCC2 downregulation was occurring in our
intratumoral and peritumoral areas where
tumor-infiltrated brain was present.
And then to evaluate that more specifically, we looked at a 3D microarray,
which
allows us to evaluate normalized spike rates across a whole brain slice.
And we found that, as expected, when you apply GAA to tumor-infiltrated
brain, that is where chloride is dysregulated, you end up with an increase in
normalized spike rate. When you apply it to a non-infiltrated portion of
brain, really nothing happens. Perhaps there's even some trend
towards inhibition. But when you add
CLP257 through this infusion, which is a KCC2
agonist, which normalizes KCC2 in this situation, you have no
effect of GAA when adding
it to tumor-infiltrated brain, indicative of GAA inducing
hyperexcitability, specifically in the glioma microenvironment in this dependent
manner.
With the help of some collaborators, we evaluated this, in an
optogenetics model. So TS516 glioma stem cells were
xenografted,
in genetically modified mice, and then opto-stimulation was performed.
And we were able to demonstrate that in AGAT
wild-type cells, you've had an increase in proliferation index, whereas
in AGAT knockout cells, that stimulation was not relevant.
And I mentioned that in GAMT deficiency, dietary
modification is critical. And the reason for that is because
this is a metabolic pathway with overflow.
So if you are able to restrict the upstream contribution and
over-supplement the downstream contribution, you should be able to modulate the
effect of the enzyme. And in this situation,
these children are supplemented with high doses of ornithine and an
arginine-restricted diet. And as a result, they can go from
intractable epilepsy to a normalized EEG relatively quickly.
So the next question being, what can we do to simulate that in a
situation where we have an aberrant metabolism in a
tumor model? And so we,
again, xenografted TS516 glioma stem cells and provided these mice
with either an overabundance of ornithine as well as an
arginine restriction, and what we saw was that these survival
benefits pretty much approach those of our genetic knockout.
And similarly, GAA was reduced in the dietary group,
but not in the normal group. And we also saw a decrease
in proliferation at the margins of these tumors in
mice who had high ornithine and arginine-restricted diets compared to a
normal diet.
So we are very shortly going to be enrolling into a surgical window of opportunity
trial of modulation of GAA. So 12 patients will be enrolled
prospectivelyThey will be supplemented with ornithine, and
they will,
on the advice of our dieticians, have a arginine restrictive
diet, which is hard to be completely deficient, but restrictive
diet three to five days before surgery, and then we'll be able to collect specimen
and determine intraoperative stereotactic sampling of brain tumor tissue for
direct quantification of GAA and other factors.
Thank you. This was truly a labor of love.
Many, many individuals here, including my longtime partner
in crime, Dr. McBrayer, and Yi Zhao, who is here as well, one of the
postdoctoral fellows in his lab. So thank you all very much.
Hi, wonderful question. I have actually several questions.
So,
starting with, it's lower and low-grade gliomas, but is it different between
IDH wild type and IDH mutant gliomas?
That's a really good question. We found that there is no difference-
Okay
... between mutational status.
What about
have you done the experiments in an immunocompetent model where
it's been shown that both L-arginine and potentially GABA have
immunomodulatory effects?
Yeah, that's a great point. We've thought about that. We haven't gotten there yet.
But that's an excellent thought.
And the last question is about this paper that came out last
year, which showed that gabapentin use is potentially
beneficial to patients with glioma.
So how do you interpret that paper in the
context of your findings?
Yeah, great question. There are a number of papers that date back
about 10 or 15 years, which have first evaluated clinically large
series of patients who've had
neuromodulation drugs, whether they be anti-epileptics or
others, which appear to confer survival benefits.
That is probably something that aligns with this hypothesis.
I can't quite pinpoint it yet in terms of gabapentin, but I think we're going
to see a lot more interest around neuromodulation as it
relates to tumor progression in the future.
Thank you very much.
Great work. We published a paper back in 2019 with an
arginine depriving agent, pegarginase, which is actually
under FDA review. Hopefully will be approved in the summer.
But we saw two out of 10 responses in refractory patients,
second, third line, and two of those patients went to two and
three years. So I'm quite intrigued with your pathway.
I was just wondering,
do you think there'll be combination approach with pegarginase plus what
you're looking at
on that? It's a linear pathway, but you might be familiar
with the BRAF, MEK linear pathway-
Yeah
... resistance.
Thank you. And I know that paper, that was a very nice paper.
Yeah, I think that the relative contributions of arginine
depletion and ornithine hyper-supplementation are something that we're still going
to tease out. For ease of use, and I think moving on to the most
immediate, we're focusing mostly on ornithine supplementation, but I
think that as we move forward, we're going to try and tease out
how much of that is arginine depletion
that has the effect that we're looking at. Thank you.
Really nice talk. I was just wondering, so this
GAA pathway seems to remind me of IDH mutant gliomas and even
other IDH mutant cancers, and this oncometabolite with 2-HG.
Do you think this is sort of a redundant mechanism that sort of co-opted by
different gliomas or other tumors to use these "oncometabolites" to,
I guess, hijack this hyperexcitability phenotype?
And then if there's time, a second question was just simply, is there any negative
feedback loop with creatine and being able to down-regulate this?
And I guess, is there a role for potential creatine
super physiologic supplementation as a negative feedback
loop?
Yeah, thank you. Let me answer that question first. It's a good question.
Creatine has so many functions within the brain that I think it's still completely
not understood.
In these diets, they do supplement a little bit of creatine for some of these,
but there are other creatine-related deficiency syndromes, and so
it gets a little bit complex, and I'm running out of time, so we can talk after
maybe.
But yeah, in terms of IDH mutation, as I look at the countdown to 15 seconds,
yeah, maybe. I think that there's a lot that goes on there
and, yeah, I think it may be co-opted and it may be mutation independent as
we show from our overall data. But that as time goes on, we're going to be able
to understand that relationship a little bit more.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Our next speaker is going to be
Dr. Sergio Attanasio. He's a postdoctoral fellow in Dr.
Viale's lab at MD Anderson Cancer Center in Houston,
and he's also a Margaret Forbes Scholar in Training awardee, and
he's going to present his work, Targeting Mitochondrial Complex I
Overcomes Adaptive Response to Chemotherapy in Advanced Pancreatic Cancer.
Thank you.
Hi, everyone. Thank you, the organizer, for
selecting my presentation and allowing me to present my work.
I am a postdoc in Dr. Viale lab, and we work on therapy resistance in
PDAC with a specific focus on mitochondrial metabolism.
So I think everybody here is familiar with this.
It's just a small overview. Most of pancreatic cancer, 90% is
adenocarcinoma with a simple genomic landscape characterized by
activating mutation KRAS and activating mutation P53,
SF3B1, and many more. It's a tumor with a very poor prognosis
that is mainly
diagnosed at advanced stage when the
tumor is not anymore localized and the surgery is not anymore
suitable. So chemotherapy is the only option with the limited
efficacy
And it's a very heterogeneous tumor as many other tumors.
And here is just a summary of how tumor
heterogeneity
can be responsible for therapy resistance. So there are different mechanisms.
This is just to give an overview.
Some clones can be
existing, present inside the tumors, and they are
responsible for tumor relapse and for minimal
residual disease. So this is Darwinian selection.
Some other clones can acquire resistance over treatment, so they have a
marker induction. And there are also a model of dynamic fluctuation,
where a specific transient cell state
can be responsible for drug tolerance states and
acquired resistance. And not all of them can coexist within the
tumor. So to address the
tumor heterogeneity, we use clonal barcoding, and this is a platform that has been
developed by Dr. Viale and published on Cell Reports in 2019,
where basically the team isolated the cells from
patients from PDAC, implant in the mice to grow.
Then you derive cells in 2D, infect
with a barcoding library at the low MOI to have one virus
per cell. And after selection with bromidine, there is
basically a stabilization process where for 20
passages, the cells are stabilizing to stabilize the barcode
composition. So to have a complexity of 10,000
barcodes, so at the end, it should start at the very beginning with much more
barcodes and much more complexity at the initial
infection. But when the curve is stabilized and the cells are
stabilized, and when checked in vivo, we have a good
representation about the clones among different animals.
So these are three different animals, and you can see that they have a
90%
common clonal barcode. So this platform is robust,
reproducible, and allow us to track the same lineages across
different animals.
So using this approach, so we injected the barcoding
PDAC cell line derived from human patients.
When the tumors grows, we treat with vaginal gemcitabine.
We collect tumors at the end of treatment, at relapse, perform NGS, and
identified around 12% of clones that
are responsible for tumor relapse and enriched in gemcitabine
relapse mice.
So then given this information, we can go back in our cells that we inject in
the... We thawed, and they are treatment naive.
Basically, we thaw the cells. We can sort hundreds of clones, and we can do a
stochastic and
isolation of these clones. And then,
based on information in vivo, we can select
the sensitive or resistant clones based on in vivo
experiment. So I select three and three.
As you can see here, this is the morphology in 2D.
They still maintain the ability on gemcitabine to
regrow. Although they are still
responsive to gemcitabine treatment, but the regrowth is much
faster compared to sensitive
in vitro, and also this is the same also in vivo.
Then using these clones,
we performed RNA sequencing and transcriptomic profiling, and we developed
a signature of chemotherapy response that is able,
as you can see here, also to detect tumor cells in
spatial
transcriptomic data, and importantly is able to predict survival in
TCGA datasets. And you can see that the sensitive arm of the signature is
associated with the better outcome in patients with PDAC.
Then we compared the signature with a different already
available signature of PDAC, so the Moffitt, Collison,
and Bailey, and also with the purity of the TCGA datasets.
And you can see that there is no correlation with the classical and basal subtypes
of PDAC, but we have a correlation with the sensitive
arm of the signature that again is associated with the better outcome in
patients with the low purity samples
in TCGA datasets. And also with some subtypes of
quasimesenchymal in Collison and immunogenic in Bailey
signature that have been questioned as a contaminant of stromal
cells. And as you can see also here, there is a
statistically significant enrich on the nonsensitive--
Sorry, of sensitive arm with the low purity.
And indeed when we performed RNA sequencing, and this is the part when we reached
the sensitive arm of the signature, we see a lot of stromal and inflammatory
genes.
Then we applied the signature to a cohort of PDACs that we have in the lab.
And again, we can stratify the PDACs.
We can validate that the sensitive are responding to the
treatment, whereas the nonsensitive do not, and also in terms of
tumor volume and also
survival.
And then when we performed transcriptomic profiling on these different cohorts of
sensitive and nonsensitive PDACs, importantly observed the toxicity
phosphorylation is an adaptive response to chemotherapy just
in the sensitive PDAC. So only the tumors that respond to chemotherapy
upregulate OXPHOS as a stress response.
We also observe an increase in OXPHOS marker,
and this is in vitro with the
one derived the cell line with the mitotracker and TMRE.
So the sensitive clones upregulate mitochondrial
respiration.
And this is conclusion for the first part.
So we developed the signature that predicts survival.
It's associated with the low purity, and we also
identify some metabolic vulnerability in this subset of tumors.
So then we ask why OXPHOS is upregulated upon
chemotherapy.Basically, we identified that
upon chemotherapy, there is an increase in mitochondrial fission that, as you can
see by increasing phospho-DRP1 by immunofluorescence,
and we also have increased by Western blot, total level.
And basically, when we knock down with shRNA the
DRP1, we don't see any more increase in the OXPHOS
upon chemotherapy.
So then we say, okay, we can target OXPHOS in this subset of patients,
in the combination therapy. With this, we use an OXPHOS inhibitor in a
complex one that is called IM-156, Lixumustat,
and is a biguanide like metformin and phenformin.
The goal here is to have a drug that is more potent than metformin, that
is not so much potent,
but less toxic than phenformin that causes lactic acidosis in patients
and has been discontinued.
And that is also the case. So, sorry.
These
are
published data, so you can see that the IM
is more potent than metformin and
phenformin inhibiting OCR, so oxygen consumption.
And this is a clinical trial conducted in South
Korea, where they also observed that basically,
just the message is here.
It's associated with the safe tolerability and safety profile
compared to other complex one inhibitor, where the lactic acidosis and
neuropathy have been, because those limited
toxicity, we validated in vitro that basically this
compound at 10 micromolar concentration is able to shut down
respiration. And then you can see in vitro that upon
gemcitabine, the cells at some point, they regrow back.
But if you have a combination treatment, you can prolong the regrowth
and also the clonogenicity. We see also an increase in cell death
by annexin staining.
We performed a metabolic evaluation on these cells,
treated with gemcitabine, IM, or combination.
And again, in the combination treatment, you can see there is an increase in a lot
of pathways associated with the pentose pathway and the reduction of TCA and
taurine and other metabolites involved important for oxidative stress.
And we performed CellROX, MitoSOX, and lipid
peroxidation. We always observe an increase of those markers in the combination
treatment that we can partially rescue with the tocopherol that is an
antioxidant. And so we conclude that
mitochondrial complex one
in combination with chemotherapy
induce oxidative cell death.
Then we move in vivo, so where we have a
gemcitabine twice a week for two weeks, and IM
that start at day third after the gemcitabine when the OXPHOS
peaks and is daily by IP for a month.
We don't see any toxicity in terms of body weight.
This is a representation
of clones responsible for tumor relapse, resistant clones.
You can see that in normal situation, untreated IM
treated mice, they represent 20% of
tumor mass. They represent 80% in gemcitabine mice
at relapse. But we can reduce, so we can
basically eradicate these clones with the combination treatment.
This is the same also with the
CCA plot. So basically, here it's just to say that the combination
treatment eradicates
clones responsible for relapse.
Then we move in vivo, where we have
an improvement, again, in tumor volume and survival with the combination
treatment.
We also performed an experiment of locally advanced residual
disease, where we basically graft tumors,
then we perform pancreas excision and perform the treatment as
adjuvant setting. And also, in this case, we observe an
improvement in survival with the combination treatment.
And thanks to this, with
Dr. Shubham Pant, we started the clinical trial at MD Anderson to
explore the safety and tolerability of this combinational
treatment. And
I would just give a very few slides.
And
basically, this is a dose escalation phase and an
expansion phase to just evaluate safety and tolerability of the
combination. And lixumustat has been
started at 400 milligrams that at the end,
the trial enrolled 18 patients, 12 for dose
escalation, six for dose expansion.
And basically, we determined that with the dose of
400 milligrams, we do not observe any major
adverse event. And 400 milligrams daily has been
identified as a recommended Phase 2 dose.
And these are some preliminary efficacy
data
where you observe that
among the evaluable patients, we have
in this
waterfall plot, you can see that two patients have a disease
progression, but
many of them have a response to the treatment.
Two of them remain on treatment for up to six and 80 weeks.
And we observe a progression-free survival of six months and overall
survival of 18 months.
So in the end, we found that
IM reduces cancer cell regrowth in PDAC
when in combination with chemotherapy by promoting oxidative stress,
is well-tolerated in mice at a dose of 15 milligram kilogram
IP daily, and they suppress tumor relapse by eradicating
clones responsible for tumor relapse.
The clinical results demonstrate that a dose of 400 milligrams of
IM PO daily combined with gemcitabine and nab-paclitaxel is safe,
tolerable, and identified as a recommended Phase 2 dose.
And the clinical results demonstrate encouraging antitumor activity of this
treatment with a partial response of 50%, disease control rate of
80%, and two patientsexhibit a durable
response exceeding one year. So at the end, I want to thank all the
people involved in this study, especially members of Dr. Vial and Dr.
Draetta lab, all the collaborators, all the patients,
and all
the funding agency, and all of you for your attention.
We have time for a question.
Yeah, sure.
Very nice work. I was just wondering, resistance is going to kick in at some point.
Have you got any thoughts about what the resistance pathways might
be?
With the combination you mean?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. Actually, we
never work on the resistance
because we are still working on-- still it's not
an active treatment, like approved treatment, so we are not
working a lot on this as of now.
We are just working to understand how we can
explore IM, maybe in combination also with other treatment like KRAS
inhibitor, or if we have to do maybe
wash, not treat every day, but maybe every other day, just to
improve the treatment regimens, the dosage,
toxicity. But that is a question that everybody asks, so probably
we'll start to think about.
Just one follow-up. I think there was a lot of excitement in the field
generally about the IX inhibitor and some of the preclinical data
generated with that complex I antagonist.
Do you have a sense of what's different with this IMS drug that you're working
with that may improve tolerability, akin to what you're seeing
in some of the early clinical results?
Yes. So the IX has been discontinued for
toxicity and failed,
unfortunately, in the clinical trial at MD Anderson.
And
basically, I'm not a chemistry-- I tried to study
this because with the non-interaction with any chemistry, probably I should talk
with some of them. And studying the
chemistry of complex I, it looks like IM
accumulates, is a big one. So it's different class compared to IX.
Mm-hmm.
So that does molecule that are variable.
IX is a very potent work in nanomolar concentration.
It looks reversible, one binds complex one, whereas
IM accumulates based on potential.
So if you have a high potential upon
chemotherapy, that's what you observe, then IM accumulates in mitochondria.
If you lose potential, IM is washed out.
So it's reversible, accumulates based on potential, so
then maybe it's less toxic. Less potent, but less toxic.
Great. Thank you.
Okay. Our
third speaker will be Dr. Gang Huang.
He's a professor of system
anatomy. Cell system anatomy, sorry.
He's from Mays Cancer Center at UT Health in Texas.
And he will present his work on how he will show us how
estrogen therapy alleviates cancer-associated cachexia in mouse
models of both sex.
Thank the committee to accept our
abstract for presentation.
We actually submitted two abstract on this topic.
One is about Warburg effect, and second story on the
estrogen. I try to cover both
stories. This is my and my PhD student's
disclosure, but this have nothing to do with today's talk.
And we all know this is a cancer incident
in the US. Prostate cancer, breast cancer, lung cancers.
And we tend to believe that's the kind of under
cause for the death. But actually, if you do
the autopsy or ask the pathologist what are the direct cause of the
death of the cancer, so basically, the number one is organ failure and
infection, sepsis shock, or the cachexia, cancer-related, which
is the wasting syndrome. Actually, almost 20% to 30% of the
patient directly die of this cancer, the cachexia.
Then what is the cancer-associated cachexia?
So basically, it's the wasting syndrome, and the advanced
cancer patient, stage three or four patient, they all have this kind
of metabolism dysfunction and severe
weight loss and muscle and fat loss and
weight loss. This is the diagnostic criteria for
that.
And my lab, working on the stem cell metabolism,
we're really interested in this phenomenon because when we working
on the liquid tumor and also the immune therapies, we always see
a phenomenon, like male mice tend to develop cachexia
very quick. Female have protection. So it's like, why was that?
And we need to have good models. So the few of those,
really made a significant progress in the past two, three decade.
One recent report show that in the
lung cancer with
STK11 or LKB1 mutations, they have
poor outcome, especially
compared to the patient with weight loss have a poor
outcome, or those patient with STK and weight loss have the worst
outcome. So those patient can be diagnosed as the lung
cancer with the cachexia. So this is a few
kind of known mutations kind of related to this
clinical kind of symptom, like cachexia.
So we try to use this clinical information to build a better
model for cachexia. So we use the KP, KRAS
PP3 lung cancer models. On top of that, deleted the
LKB1, so we call it the KPL. We also have a very
aggressive melanoma B16 lines, which also
develop quick kind
of-So here is the
data for the KP and the KPL. This is isogenic cell
lines. You can see here, this is the control mice,
mid-age kind of mice, and this is the KP.
So tumor grows similarly in the KPL, but at almost like at
day 16, these KPL cell
tumor-inoculated mice start to decline.
And this is the total body weight. And if you
do the kind of autopsy, we can see this is the
fat,
this is the
muscle. So you can see, compare with KP, they also have the tumor,
similar size of a tumor, but in the KPL, they develop, this is fat
tissue, this is muscle tissue, develop the cachexia.
And interestingly, in the same kind of onset of
time, onset of the cachexia, we also see very severe
anemia. So you see the day 16, the total
RBC hemoglobin and also hematocrit
decrease.
So, first we want to know what's the tumor, like a cell
intrinsic effect, lead to this kind of phenomena.
So we did a whole bunch of RNA-seq metabolism.
Here we show the RNA-seq. So basically compare with the KP, KPL
with LKB1 mutation, have a significantly
upregulated hypoxia response to hypoxia pathways.
If you zoom in, look at those hypoxia HIF
targeted genes, many of them are upregulated, include L 六 or other kind
of inflammation cytokines, which have already been implicated in
the
cachexia.
So, next question is whether we can pharmacologically
inhibit this pathway. So we
want to use some FDA-approved drug.
Unfortunately, there is no FDA-approved HIF1 alpha inhibitor,
but there is a HIF2 alpha inhibitors for kidney cancer or
other kind of pseudo hypoxia-related cancers.
So we try to use that. So, with the KP vehicle,
KPL vehicle, and then we treat with the HIF alpha 2
inhibitor, rezotibib. And you can see the green
one, the tumor grows similarly, but then we can see
the HIF 2 inhibitions. We can rescue the
total body weight, we can rescue the fat, and also
rescue the muscle. But unfortunately, this drug
doesn't really help the anemia. As you know,
our EPO produced by the kidney and driven by the HIF.
So this drug, clinical side effect is
reduce the EPO level and also worsens the anemia.
So on top of this drug, we also add the EPO and the transfusion.
And now you can see here we can rescue the anemia, and
we can also maintain the
benefit for the white fat and also the muscle.
So basically, we believe this kind of new therapies maybe can
help the cancer patient beyond kidney cancer or
other HIF-driven cancer.
So, to summarize the first part, it's a complex
slide, but its take-home message is easy.
So you know the cancer, early developed cancer or small cancers, they
tend to be low Warburg effect, and the tumor can balance
the use of the glucose and also the fatty acid.
And then they don't really have much kind of burdens to the body
or reprogram the peripheral tissues.
But in case of a high Warburg tumor, so when tumor get bigger,
hypoxia, then they trigger additional mutation, for example, the LKB1
mutations, then they shut down the MPK.
Now they shut down the fatty acid oxidation.
Now they have to turn on the HIF pathways and then
rely heavily on the glycolysis
glucose and also pentose phosphate for the proliferation.
And in this settings, they need
a lot of the glucose and pump out a lot of lactate.
They also secrete a lot of HIF target
cytokines in the circulation system.
So basically, over the time, they will reprogram the peripheral tissue
and then lead to the fat mass loss and also the anemia.
So we believe like a HIF inhibition, especially in the future, if there
is an S, the kind of HIF 1/2 double inhibitors, they
will reprogram the tumor and
eventually also reprogram the peripheral tissues and prevent
the
cachexia and also the
anemia, which also lead to hypoxia.
And this is one nice second part. A very nice
review from Teresa,
showed actually in clinic, people find this all the time.
Male patients they tend to have a more high incidence of cachexia
and a high mortality. The
female seems to have a protection.
But the scientific question is whether
we can see this in mice. Actually, we use a more aggressive melanoma
lines, same as the KPL. We can see that.
You see the female tumor inoculation, although the tumors grow, but
they don't really have the weight loss.
But the male have severe weight loss.
And if you look at the fat and the muscle, same.
Female doesn't really change much, but the male have a severe
loss of the fat and the muscle. You can see here, this is the tissue.
This is the female with the tumor.
Again, look at whether is the female have protection or
male worse outcome. So we decided to do the ovary
ectomy and also the castration. So this is
the
OBX. You can see the female have a protection, but when we give the
compare with the sham OBX, now they start to develop cachexia.
This is the fat, this is the muscle.And then the male mice,
we did the castration compared with the sham or the controls,
they're pretty much the same. So basically,
the castration doesn't really change the phenotype, but rather the
ovary or some hormone from the ovaries probably have this
effect. Then we look at the RNA-seq.
So we found in the white adipose tissue, the same as the
muscle and the liver, we can see the same kind of trend.
The tissue transcriptome indicate the male tumor-bearing cachexia
mice show a broad metabolism deregulation, especially the
lot of the
mitochondrial kind of pathway, fatty acid beta-oxidation was down in
those tissues.
And then we decided to treat the cachexia mice,
male mice, and female mice with the
OAX mice with the E2. Here we show data about
male mice bearing the B16 tumor, and then we used
a
slow-release pellet of the
E2 to treat. You can see compared with the vehicle, the male mice
and the tumor-inoculated mice with treated with E2, they can
maintain the body weight. They can also
maintain the fat and also the muscle compared with the control.
So we also harvest a lot of different tissue, did the
transcriptome and the metabolism
data
profile. So the treatment, the E2, stopped IRAD and also the lean
muscle catabolism program block the cancer.
So you can see the
OXPHOS TCA cycle was up, and then the proteolysis,
a lot of the amino acid, the kind of pathway was down in the
E2-treated male mice.
And here is the peripheral blood. As you know, when the mouse develop cachexia
and it circulate a lot of the fatty acid and also the amino acid.
So we use this
serum kind of metabolism biomarker to see that.
So this is the control female with the tumor, and they
change a little bit, but not that much.
And the red one is the male mice with the
cachexia. You see they severely kind of secrete a lot of
the catabolism kind of metabolites in the circulation system.
And the yellow one is the male mice treated with the E2.
So after three weeks, they pretty much kind of
reverse from here to here and very close to the
female metabolites. You can see here in the peripheral--
In the serum, many of these
tissue kind of
metabolism
component from the fat and the muscle was kind of
reversed by the E2 treatment.
Because of time, we don't introduce all of the data, but
we have
a lot of the transcriptome and the metabolism data.
I just want to summarize the parties here.
So I already introduced this HIF inhibition, which
can benefit but need additional kind of
anemia kind of therapy. For example, the EPO or the
transfusions. But in case the estrogen, somehow the
estrogen can really kind of inhibit all those
pathways active with the mitochondria TCA cycle, and
balance the glycolysis and glucose need, and also
maintain the fat and also the muscle tissue.
With that, I have to thank. This is my lab and the
people who did the work, and especially I want to thank the two
collaborators along the lung cancer side, Lingtao Ji, and
also Theresa really help us, kind of
keep us in track to understand and also answer
the right question for the people. Thank you so much.
Thank you very much, Dr. Huang. We have time for one
question.
Well, I do have a question. So given the role of the
hormones in the strategy that you are presenting,
is there any difference between the different types of breast cancer that are
positive or negative for their hormone receptors?
Yes, that's a excellent questions.
And so we don't know, because ER, alpha,
beta, and there are also a GP ER. So
GPCR is a kind of downstream of the estrogen. We don't know.
But if you look at those kind of pathways,
especially the related TCA cycle and the metabolism, both alpha and beta,
especially the beta. And now we are using the
E2 because it's actually kind of approved drug.
But we're also interested whether specific kind of agonists are
going to
also have this kind of therapeutic efficacy. We don't really know which is which.
But from the kind of fat, because this is the whole body things-
Mm.
-it's hard to believe one of the kind of estrogen receptor
taking care of everything.
Mm.
But probably different tissues are different.
So our best bet right now is using E2 instead of going
choosing into the individual.
Yeah. No, especially with the results that you presented in the white adipose
tissue, probably they are going to be, yeah.
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Okay, so the next speaker
is Dr. Omid
Hajihassani.
He is a surgery fellow at Case Western Reserve.
And he's going to present his work about a ketogenic diet
sensitized pancreatic cancer to metabolic therapies. Thank you.
Thank you for the introduction and for having me today.
I'm going to discuss today how dietary changes in pancreatic cancer
would potentially reveal new targetable pathways that we can rationalize a good
combination therapy to combat PDAC.
Pancreatic cancer is the third leading cause of cancer-related death in the United
States, and it's projected to be the second leading cause of cancer-related death
by mid-2030s.
Unfortunately, one of the reasons for poor prognosis
is the lack of chemotherapy in the field.
Right now, the best therapeutics that we have are the two chemotherapies of
gemcitabine or FOLFIRINOX, which date back to '80s and
'90s with a lot of side effects. So many people don't even qualify to undergo
these therapeutics. And even if they qualify,
the average survival is about 11 months and seven
months. So we hypothesized that maybe one
way to combat PDAC would be designing a
good combination therapy through metabolism inhibition, and
hopefully improve survival for pancreatic cancer patients.
But what do we know about pancreatic cancer metabolism?
A study
published in 2015 from the Pinia lab suggested that pancreatic cancer
comes in two major flavors. They're either glycolytic or lipogenic.
Glycolytic cell lines have weaker mitochondria,
lower mitochondrial potential. They do not use carbon tracer in
the form of glucose in lipids or alpha KG
to push through a TCA cycle. However, lipogenic cell lines,
they have a stronger mitochondria, and they show a lot of
metabolites in their TCA cycle.
So this built a foundation for us. We took a cell line
like MiaPaCa. We rationalized that if a cell line is known to be glycolytic,
maybe we can push it with diet, like ketogenic diet, and succumb
the tumor growth.
But before I show you data, I would like to introduce what is a ketogenic diet.
A ketogenic diet is a diet that is high in fat and low in carbohydrate.
It's different than high fat diet.
A ketogenic diet has to push body through the state of ketosis.
A state of ketosis is a process of using fatty acid to producing
ketone bodies. But what does it mean for tumors?
For tumors, pretty much it means that under an average Western diet, tumor is
capable to pick up nutrient in a form of carbohydrate,
make glucose, and use that glucose to push through glycolysis,
TCA cycle, and other macromolecules to grow.
However, under a ketogenic diet, tumor has to rely on ketone
bodies, and ketone bodies are made in liver from fatty acids.
So from the beginning, we have a diet that will
inhibit glycolysis to not produce enough nutrient for
glycolysis, and these tumors have to use their TCA cycle
as a major source of nutrient production and energy production.
In the field to date, we have multiple studies that have been published on
the effect of ketogenic diet in combination therapy with other
therapeutics. I have three of them here.
The first study is from the laboratory of Dr.
Cantley, where they showed that ketogenic diet in combination with PI3K
inhibitor shows a stronger anticancer effect.
And the reason for it is that ketogenic diet has lower amount of carbohydrate.
We have lower amount of insulin, so PI3K inhibitors would be more efficient.
The second study from the laboratory of Dr.
Vander Heiden suggests that ketogenic diet alone does not have much of an
effect. However, if we change the source of fatty acid and
make them more saturated, we might be able to get some anticancer
efficacy from ketogenic diet. And the third study from the laboratory
of Dr. Ruggiero from UCSF shows that the effectiveness
of ketogenic diet comes in inhibition and combination therapy with inhibitor
of ketone body utilization genes.
What you can see in common between all three studies, and all the studies in the
field, is that all the studies suggest that ketogenic diet alone is
not going to be effective. And all of these three studies that I showed here, it
shows that there are different angles that ketogenic diet in a
combination therapy can be effective.
So there is a lot more to discover. And what we have studied is that
every time that we administered ketogenic diet, we saw that the tumor
progression was slower, survival was longer, but even
after 227 days, we still have tumor in the mice,
but they're just growing slower.
So we ask a question that how does a ketogenic diet cause adaptation?
What are the adaptation pathway that arises from ketogenic diet?
For the first step, we did a series of metabolomics, and we saw that
a cell line like MiaPaCa that historically has been established to be glycolytic,
under ketogenic diet condition, their tumors become
TCA cycle dependent. They upregulate TCA cycle activity.
They have more metabolites in their TCA cycle.
We also saw that when we administered ketogenic diet in the serum, we have a lot of
fatty acid upregulation. However, in the tumor, selected few of those fatty
acids are upregulated. And finally, by accident, which
we didn't expect, we saw that when we give ketogenic diet, we see high
levels of glutamine, both in the serum and in the tumor.
It's almost four times higher in the tumor, the levels of glutamine when we
administer ketogenic diet. So we ask, what is the main source of the glutamine?
Where is glutamine coming from? For the first round of experiment, we did a series
of isotope tracing using glucose labels, ketone body
labels, and capric acid as a source of fatty acid to see
if pancreatic cancer cells like MiaPaCa would be able to make their own
glutamine. What we observed is that majority of the
glycolysis labels are coming from glucose.
Majority of the TCA cycle labels come from fatty acid and ketone
bodies. And even though the labels go all the way to produce
glutamate, they do not make glutamine.
This suggested that the cancer cells under ketogenic diet do not make their own
glutamine. So glutamine has to come from somewhere else.
Through our collaboration with MacArthur Laboratory at Harvard, we observed that
when we reduce the amount of protein in the diet, going from 20%
protein to 10% to 6%, every increment of
reduction in... dietary protein, we have
upregulation in the amount of glutamine that the liver
produces and puts into the blood. So there is a glutamine
recycling in the liver during the ketogenic diet, and this glutamine that
we see in the tumor, four times higher, is probably coming from the
liver. So what we did next is that we know that glutamine is coming from the
liver, but does tumor actually have the capability to pick it up?
And when we did a series of RNA sequencing and
western blotting, we saw that the channels to uptake glutamine under
ketogenic diet conditions are upregulated.
We have more channels to
pick up more glutamine, and we have more enzyme that utilize glutamine.
So at this point, we know that the glutamine levels are higher.
We know that the ability of the tumor to pick up glutamine is higher, and they do
have the machinery to utilize it. Next, we did a series of isotope tracing with
glutamine, and we saw that, yes, pancreatic cancer, not only they are capable to
pick up the glutamine, they're actually capable of utilizing this glutamine
to feed their TCA cycle.
All of this data so far shows that we have more glutamine in the tumor,
but we cannot say that tumors are dependent on glutamine.
We can only suggest that tumors are dependent on glutamine if we show that the flux
of glutamine is faster and the glutamine is being utilized
faster in the tumor. So to show that the flux is faster and
utilization is higher, we did a series of isotope tracing, this
time, time-based. We looked at the utilization of glutamine
at half an hour, one hour, two hour, and three hour.
We saw that at half an hour, when we remove all the glutamine from the media and
replace it with M5 glutamine, isotope tracer of glutamine,
right off the bat, we have more glutamine in the ketogenic diet condition.
We saw it in the tumor, we see it in the cell culture.
After three hours, the amount of glutamine in both condition, ketogenic
diet and control diet, reached to be the same amount.
When we start at the higher levels and reach the same amount, it means that the
velocity and utilization was faster. We push it further.
We look into the glutamate. We look into alpha-KG and aspartate
at M3. We wanted to see if M5 is also being utilized faster.
And we saw that the M3 glutamate, alpha-KG, and aspartate, they
do have higher peaks for glutamine
utilization under ketogenic diet condition.
With this information, we rationalize that maybe during a ketogenic diet, one of
the pathways that we can target would be the combination therapy with
CBA39 and DON, two different inhibitors of glutamine.
And we saw that the combination therapy of glutamine inhibitors with ketogenic diet
shows a stronger anti-cancer efficacy compared to the
monotherapy.
The findings that are reported here is going to be online.
We published this finding in Cell Reports Medicine, and on April 23, you will
see the full story. And for the next step of this project,
we are thinking that a ketogenic diet is going to create a new
environment for us. We are going to see a lot of adaptation.
We saw that previous studies shows PI3K inhibition.
They showed that there is a higher
efficacy with saturated fatty acid.
We showed that glutamine could potentially be one of those pathway that can be
targeted. And we think that maybe like FOLFIRINOX, a
chemotherapy for pancreatic cancer that has multiple
chemotherapy drugs being combined, maybe we can design a multiple
drugs as a metabolic modulators and use that to fight
pancreatic cancer and hopefully get better survival.
I would like to thank our lab, Vinter Lab, the AACR committee for
selecting this abstract, and all
of you for your time and attention. I look forward to your questions. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Is there any question in the audience?
Well, I do have a question.
Sure.
So I really like this
work.
But
what do you think is the effect that is happening in the immune cells in the
pancreas? Do you think they are also, because as you said, all the microenvironment
seems to be changed by this change in the biochemistry
of the tumor. So what is happening with immune cells?
That's a very good question. And actually, we have started to look into the tumor
microenvironment. I didn't show that data here. It's not also in that paper.
We are publishing it as a next step for the tumor microenvironment.
What we observe is in two different models, the GEM models and KPC models.
When we put these mice on ketogenic diet versus control diet, there is not
much of a difference in the markers of immune system.
We don't see higher exhaustion, and we also don't see a lot of
activation. It remains steady between the two conditions.
Mm-hmm. Do you see changes in the localization of these
immune cells in the pancreas?
I haven't looked at that.
Okay.
Yeah, that's something that I haven't looked at, but it's very important, and we
have to do that as a next step. Definitely.
Thank you.
I think you have another question.
Just one quick follow-up.
The evidence that CBA39 synergizes
suggests that glutamate production is important, but do you know for sure
that import of carbons from glutamate into the TCA cycle is what's
relevant? Or are there other glutamate-dependent metabolic processes
that might be contributing to some of the activity that you're seeing?
That is a very good question. I think one of the ways that we can study that is by
tracing glutamate in mice-
Mm
... and looking at it in vivo. We've never done that study to see the glutamate
contribution to the pathway. But in the data that I showed earlier, it
suggests that not only glutamine levels are higher in the tumor, but glutamate is
also higher. It could be both that
glutamine converts to glutamate, and also there is another source
of glutamate in the system-
Mm-hmm
... that is contributing to that pool.
Do you see effects on glutathione, for example?
Yes. ROS biology definitely is being affected.
Yeah.
For a cell line that is dependent on glycolysis, when they adapt to ketogenic diet,
we see a lot of ROS upregulation.
Mm-hmm.
And glutathione and NADPH levels are affected.
Yeah. It'd be interesting to look if one of the effects of CB 839 is on the
glutathione axis as opposed to strictly on TCA cycle flux.
Yeah.
Very good question. Thank you.
Great talk.
Appreciate that.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, our next speaker is Devashi Sen.
He's a graduate student in David DeNardo's lab at
Washington University School of Medicine in St.
Louis. And the title of his talk is Metabolic Changes Associated with
Senescence in CAFs Regulate Fibrosis in Pancreatic
Cancer.
Thank you. And also, I want to thank the organizing committee
for giving the opportunity to present my work at this
year's annual meeting.
Good evening, everyone. Today I will be presenting my
ongoing doctoral work,
which addresses the role of senescent CAF metabolism in
pancreatic cancer fibrosis.
I don't have anything to disclose.
Pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma, or PDAC, is the third leading cause of
cancer-related death in the United States, with only
13% of patients living beyond five years.
The dismal prognosis of this disease is because of its highly metastatic
nature and its refractoriness to standard cytotoxic and
immune therapy.
The treatment unresponsiveness of this disease is
largely because of its unique fibrotic and
stroma-rich microenvironment, where cancer-associated fibroblasts
become one of the major cell types, as can be seen in this
multiplex IHC image where yellow and red
marks total CAF as well as a subtype of
CAF in PDAC tumor microenvironment.
Cancer-associated fibroblasts, or CAF, play a crucial role in
TME.
It deposits extracellular matrix as well as it can remodel extracellular matrix.
It can regulate antitumor immune responses and can
fuel energetics as well as proliferation of tumor cells.
However, in PDAC, studies that have targeted
CAF has shown both pro and antitumorigenic outcome.
And the reason behind this can be found in the phenotypic and
functional heterogeneity of CAF in the tumor microenvironment.
In PDAC, three subpopulation of CAFs are well known,
which are inflammatory CAF, antigen-presenting CAF, and
myofibroblastic CAF. Moreover, there are other subpopulation
of CAFs that has been identified with particular markers such
as LRRC15, CD105, and FAP.
Adding to this heterogeneity, our recent work has
identified a subpopulation of myofibroblasts that has
undergone senescence and regulate PDAC progression.
Under the presence of external and internal stress, such as
genotoxic stress, oncogene activation, and telomere erosion,
cell activate signaling cascade leading to upregulation of cell
cycle inhibitor such as P16 and P21,
which leads to irreversible arrest in cell cycle.
Along with this, there are several cell autonomous and
non-autonomous events occur, such as chromatin
rearrangement, metabolic reprogramming, and these cells secrete a
plethora of signaling and matrix remodeling protein, which are
collectively known as senescence-associated secretory phenotype.
So we identified a subset of CAF, particularly
myofibroblasts, that have undergone senescence,
as can be seen in this multiplex IHC images where the
top panel are tumor from genetic mouse model of PDAC, which is
KP-PC, and the bottom panel is a human PDAC
sample. And you can see these green
P16-expressing senescent cells, and you can appreciate that these
cells are particularly restricted to these alpha-SMA expressing
myofibroblasts, suggesting these senescent cells are just a
subpopulation of myofibroblasts.
Moreover,
when we orthotopically co-implanted senescent fibroblasts with
PDAC cell line,
it led to more tumor burden as compared to implantation of
non-senescent fibroblasts with PDAC cell line,
suggesting senescent fibroblasts promote PDAC progression.
To ask what senescent fibroblasts are doing in PDAC
tumor microenvironment, we utilized this genetic mouse model called
Ink-Tag, and we combined this mouse with our
genetic mouse model of PDAC, which is KP-PC.
And depletion of senescent cells in this model led to
less collagen abundance in PDAC tumor
microenvironment, which was evaluated using Sirius red staining
and can be seen in this representative image as well as in
the quantification.
Moreover, we found that the collagen one
matrix deposited by senescent fibroblasts have
thicker fiber as compared to a matrix deposited by
non-senescent fibroblasts.
So we asked how senescent fibroblasts promote
fibrosis in PDAC tumor microenvironment, and our
hypothesis is metabolic reprogramming in
senescent CAF promote a fibrotic microenvironment in
PDAC.
To test this hypothesis, first,
we tested whether senescent
CAF are metabolically distinct as compared to myofibroblasts.
Towards this, we utilized single-cell RNA sequencing
library generated from sorted CAF from tumor
isolated from genetic mouse model of PDAC.
And dimensional reduction analysis demonstrated this presence of
purple cluster, which shows transcriptional signature of
senescence.Gene set enrichment analysis
demonstrated transcriptional enrichment of oxidative
phosphorylation and glycolysis in senescent CAF.
Since mitochondria are the hub of oxidative phosphorylation,
next we asked whether mitochondrial abundance and mitochondrial
function is altered in senescent fibroblasts.
To verse this, we induced senescence in primary pancreatic
fibroblasts using a DNA-damaging agent, bleomycin,
and assessed the mitochondrial content using MitoTracker and
mitochondrial potential using a TMRM dye.
And as can be seen here, although the induction of senescence led to
more mitochondrial content, the mitochondrial potential per
mitochondria is dampened in senescent fibroblasts,
suggesting potential impairment in mitochondrial function.
Moreover, to get a holistic overview of metabolic changes
associated with senescence, we performed untargeted metabolomics
and metabolite set enrichment analysis demonstrated
upregulation of glycolysis in senescent fibroblasts.
When we zoom in, we see enrichment of several glycolytic
intermediates in senescent fibroblasts.
However, interestingly, in TCA cycle, although the initial
metabolites such as citric acid and alpha-ketoglutaric acid is
enriched in senescent fibroblasts, the later metabolites like
succinate and malic acid are dampened.
I found this accumulation of
alpha-ketoglutarate in senescent fibroblasts
particularly interesting, since for the proper
folding as well as triplex formation of collagen, it
need to undergo proline and lysine hydroxylation.
And the enzymes which are involved in this process, such as
lysyl as well as prolyl hydroxylase, utilize
alpha-ketoglutarate as a substrate.
Supporting this, we found that senescent CAF
showed transcriptional upregulation of several prolyl as well as
lysyl hydroxylases.
Moreover, coming back to the accumulation of
alpha-ketoglutarate in senescent fibroblasts, we
found that the enzymes which are involved in
alpha-ketoglutarate production, which are IDH2 and
IDH3, are upregulated in senescent CAF.
Particularly, it was interesting because IDH2 and IDH3 are involved
in mitochondrial alpha-ketoglutarate production, although the IDH1 is
involved in cytosolic.
So the ongoing work is targeting IDH2
and IDH3 in senescent CAF and assessing its
effect on ECM production by senescent
CAF.
With that,
I want to thank my PI, Dr. David DiNardo, my current lab.
Moreover, I want to extend my acknowledgement to Dr.
Sheila Stewart's lab in WashU, as well as Dr.
Paolo Provenzano's lab in University of Minnesota.
I also want to thank MJ at
MTAC for metabolomics, as well as NCI, as
well as Washington University for funding.
With that, thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to take questions.
Okay. Any questions from the audience?
Maybe I'll start out here. Do you have a sense for the molecular
mechanism that links the senescence program with induction
of mitochondrial activity?
So I have not tested in our model, but there are
several models which is known in the field.
One of the
mechanism is that because
for senescence induction, DNA damage is one of the common
event which occur, and lot of enzymes, particularly PARP,
which is a NAD-dependent
enzyme, deplete NAD, which leads to mitochondrial dysfunction.
Interesting.
And I guess one follow-up. It's sort of interesting to think about activating
a collagen biosynthesis program, but depleting AKG at the
same time. Have you tried to intervene and block AKG
supply to collagen-modifying enzymes?
And if so, does that lead to any proteostasis-related stress
or
toxic accumulation of procollagens within those cells?
Yeah. So those are exactly the experiments we are
doing to see, trying to see whether if we
inhibit this pathway, whether that can affect the
whole collagen production.
Mm-hmm.
Mostly ex vivo currently, but later want to go to in vivo.
All right.
I have a question.
So you mentioned that there is an increase
in the alpha-ketoglutaric acid. Do you know if this acid
is accumulated in the fibroblasts or is released
to the microenvironment?
Yes. So we have also done
metabolomics on the condition media.
And as much I remember, the citric acid was high, but
alpha-ketoglutaric acid was not high in the condition media.
So yeah.
All right. That's what we wanted.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay. Our next speaker is Dr. Alvaro Gutierrez.
He's a member of David Sodransky's lab, Johns Hopkins
University.
I'm not sure if I've seen Dr. Gutierrez.
He might be on
MiRAOkay.
I take that back. Our next speaker is Dr. Myra Di Tano.
She's a postdoctoral fellow in Marcos Goncalves's lab
at NYU. The title of her talk is Targeting
Metabolism in BRCA Deficient Tumors.
Thanks for your flexibility.
Of course. Thank you for the introduction and this opportunity.
Okay.
So I'm happy to share with you our data regarding
metabolism in BRCA deficient tumors.
So BRCA genes
are tumor suppressor genes, and they are key players in
homologous recombination gene repair pathway, which is an
error-free gene repair mechanism that fuels their survival
and maintains genome integrity. When BRCA genes get mutated,
homologous recombination gets impaired, and so the cells
need to use other alternative pathways which are usually error prone to
repair their DNA damage, and this fuels genomic instability, cell
death, and can lead to cancer.
And this is the reason why individuals with germline mutation in one of the copies
of these genes showed increased susceptibility to develop
different tumors.
So the main question, the main goal of this project is to understand whether and
how loss of BRCA genes may affect tumor metabolism.
And to answer these complicated questions, we
started with a simple in vitro system, which is the LD1 cell line,
which are isogenic cell line, BRCA2 wild type and BRCA2 knockout.
We interrogated them through RNA-Seq, and we could see
that among the top 10 hits, glycolysis/gluconeogenesis was
altered. And then we decided to look at the different protein
expression level of the different enzymes of glycolysis to see whether
they were altered. And we found that that was the case, and in
particular, we found an upregulation of pyruvate kinase upon
loss of BRCA2. So pyruvate kinase is the
enzyme which catalyzes the last step of glycolysis, which converts
phosphoenolpyruvate into pyruvate and generates ATP.
PKM gene gives rise to two different alternative splicing isoforms,
PKM1 and PKM2. So they both catalyze the very same
reaction. The only difference is that PKM1 is constitutively active,
instead PKM2 is less active, and it can be allosterically
regulated. And what we know so far is that cancer cells
preferentially express the M2 isoform, so the less active one,
because this gives them more flexibility and sustains tumor
growth. So given our data showing that pyruvate kinase was
upregulated upon loss of BRCA2, we wanted to dig in more
into the two different isoforms. And we were surprised to find
that the loss of BRCA2 induces the overexpression of the
M1 isoform rather than the expected M2.
And we found this in two different cell lines, the LD1 and ID8, at the
RNA level, at the protein level, and also if we look at the activity.
And this is in knockout models, so we wanted to see whether this could be
recapitulated also in a transient, acute model.
And also BRCA2 knockdown, just 48 hours of BRCA2 knockdown
was sufficient to upregulate M1 isoform in both cell lines
at RNA and protein level. And we could also see similar
results if we act on BRCA1. Also, if we do
knockdown of BRCA1 in the LD1, as well as
BRCA1 knockout clones in ID8.
And then we moved in vivo, and so we could see harvesting tumors from
tumor-bearing mice, we found the same results.
So M1 isoform was upregulated in BRCA2 knockout tumors,
but PKM2 was barely affected, and this happened at the protein
level measured by Western blot and immunochemistry, as well as if we look
at the activity, we can see the increase in activity is mainly due to
M1 isoform.
So then the next question is, okay, so loss of BRCA2 leads to this
high pyruvate kinase metabolic state, but can be thus
exploited as a metabolic vulnerability.
So as I mentioned before,
tumor cells or I would say most of tumor cells express
M2, the less active, which sustain tumor growth.
So this gave the rationale to develop PKM2
activators. So kind of mimicking or phenocopying a
constitutively active M1.
And different molecules have been developed, such as dasatinib,
TAP46, but they
didn't pass the preclinical stage because of lack of
efficacy in cancer context. So today we have mitapivat,
which is an FDA-approved PKM activator, which instead is used for
hemolytic anemia, so not in cancer.
However, these activators were tested in tumors, and they were not
effective enough, but the tumors have never been stratified according to their
BRCA mutational status, and this is what we wanted to do.
So we treated the cells with dasatinib, which is the PKM2
activator, and we could see that the activator selectively increased cell
death in BRCA2 knockouts tumor cells, not in the wild type.
And we can also see an upregulation of DNA damage markers, such as the
phosphorylation of gamma H2AX.
So then the question is, is this enhanced sensitivity
to the drug kind of correlated to
PKM1 upregulation? So to answer these questions, we
upregulated PKM1. We overexpressed PKM1 in BRCA2
wild type cells, as you can see here.
And we found that
PKM1 overexpression was sufficient to significantly enhance the
sensitivity to the activator in BRCA2 wild type cells,
suggesting that possibly this high pyruvate kinase activity state
mediated by PKM1 overexpression is at least in
part involved in this mechanism of sensitization
to the activator.And then we wanted to see whether
these findings could have some translational relevance
in vivo. And we used mitapivat, the FDA-approved drug,
in tumor-bearing mice. And we could see that mitapivat delayed tumor
growth selectively in BRCA knockout tumor cells, but not in the wild type.
And this treatment was also pretty safe since we saw that there was no changes
in body weight through the course of the experiment, as well as no
changes in weight of the target toxicity organs, liver and ovary.
So then the question was, why loss of BRCA2
leads to decreased sensitivity to PK activators.
What is the mechanism behind this?
And we could see that the activation of pyruvate kinase leads
to mitochondrial dysfunction, impacts mitochondria, and in fact,
by
doing tracing experiments using 13C glucose, we could
follow the fate of different glucose carbons, and we could see that the
drug, as well as the loss of BRCA2, leads to a decrease in
glucose oxidation measured by TCA cycle intermediates, malate,
and citrate. And this is consistent with also the
observation that there is a downregulation of the protein expression
level of the different complexes of the respiratory
chain. We also looked at PINK1,
which is a marker of mitochondrial quality and
mitophagy regulation. And what we found is that the activator in
BRCA2 wild-type cells causes a shift of PINK1 bands,
which indicates the autophosphorylation of PINK1, and so mitophagy
activation. Instead, what happens in BRCA2 knockout
cells with or without the drug, is that there is a downregulation of
PINK1 expression level, which may indicate
impairment of
mitophagy control. And this downregulation could be
phenocopied by overexpressing PKM1
in BRCA2 wild-type cell, as well as giving the product of the
reaction, which is pyruvate.
So given this data, in fact, showing that mitochondria are impacted,
we wanted to see whether mitochondria were going through some kind of
oxidative damage. And we found that
the drug, DAZ-508, the activator, causes
superoxide generation selectively in
mitochondria in both BRCA2 wild-type and BRCA2 knockout cells.
So then we wanted to see whether this oxidative stress in the
mitochondria may lead to impairment in mitophagy.
And so we looked at markers of mitophagy and autophagy, and we showed that
they were actually altered. In particular, the fact is stronger in
BRCA2 knockout cells with the drug.
And so it's showing that there is an impairment of the autophagic
flux. And this was also consistent with the fact that
we found an accumulation of multivesicular bodies measured
by EM selectively in BRCA knockout cells with the
activator.
Given these findings, we wanted to see whether this mitochondrial
oxidative stress was upstream and was the cause of all
these consequences. So we treated the cells with antioxidants,
and we could see that glutathione, and more effectively, the
superoxide dismutase mimetic, was able to reverse
the cell death induction caused by the drug in BRCA2 knockout
cells, suggesting that the oxidative stress, specifically in the mitochondria,
was the leading cause of this effect.
So to summarize, our working model is that
BRCA2-deficient cells grow in this highly active pyruvate
kinase state, which is mainly due to PKM1
expression. And if we further activate pyruvate
kinase with the activator, this leads to mitochondrial oxidative
stress and mitophagy and autophagy impairments leading to cell
death.
And with this, I want to thank my mentor, Marcos Goncalves, Luke
Cantley, all the members of the Goncalves Lab who helped me with the
project, all the collaborators, my funding sources.
I want to thank the American Italian Cancer Foundation and the Italian
Association for Cancer Research Fellowship, devoted in
memory of Francesca Barbieri. And thank you all for your attention.
Happy to take any questions.
Thank you. Any questions?
So great talk.
Thank you.
Thank you. So I was curious to know whether you also measured the cytoplasmic
levels of radical oxygen species.
And in addition to this, if you tried to combine the PK activator
with drugs that are known to be effective in BRCA deficient cells,
such as platinum compounds or PARP inhibitors, for instance. Thank you.
Yeah. Okay, thank you for your question.
So I didn't measure the oxidative stress in the cytoplasm, but
that's actually one thing that's next, is to compare that with
the mitochondrial.
So that we still don't know, but we will do that.
And for the second questions, we tried to combine
mitapivat with PARP inhibitors in vitro.
We observe an additive effect. We want to move in vivo,
and we are actually interested in seeing whether there is an additive
synergistic effect, and also if it has any
effect in the resistance appearance
or which is the effect of mitapivat in BRCA cells that are
already resistant to PARP. So we don't have the data yet,
but definitely wanted something what we wanted to do.
Thank you. You observed the increased DNA damage when you
combined the two-
Yeah
... courses? Okay, this could be potentially mediated also by an increased
accumulation of ROS, for instance?
Yeah. So we hypothesized that that's the damage that we
observe in mitochondria that then leads to DNA damage.
We
wanted to see
whether this can also beCan be increased
with PARP inhibitors. We don't see any difference in PARylation.
So
that's why we think that something mediating the mitochondria and not in the DNA
damage pathway.
Thank you.
You partially answered my question on the PARP resistance,
but have you looked in your in vitro models or in vitro
models where
people have generated resistance or where you restore
BRCA function
if your metabolic switch is hardwired or not?
Because that would be a really interesting first step.
No. We didn't do that yet, but it's our next step.
We have an ovarian cancer cell line that are
BRCA2 mutated, and then they were resistant to PARP
inhibitors. And so we want to test in those cell lines the effect of the drug
as well as M1M2 regulation.
Thank you.
Great work. I was just wondering if you could speculate on what is
driving the expression changes in PKM2, and
if you ever see in
a olaparib-resistant BRCA mutant tumors, do you also see
an increased expression of PKM2?
Okay. So we have no data
about why upon loss of
BRCA2, we observe this increase in M1
isoform. We think that there is both a transcription regulation as well as
splicing regulation.
However, our main hypothesis is that,
because the
pyruvate kinase catalyze the conversion from PEP to pyruvate, but it also
generates ATP.
So our guess is that this BRCA knockout cells requires more
ATP to repair DNA damage, and so we wanted
to test whether the reason why they are expressing
M1 is because their ATP requirement is higher.
Cool.
So we will do that.
Thank you.
Interesting data.
Okay.
I was just wondering, do you know
what signaling mechanism is regulating your autophagy or
your mitophagy? Have you checked mTOR signaling or
something like that?
Yeah. We want to look more into the details of the mitophagy
regulation. We looked at pink, but we also want to look at
parklin and all the pathway.
And yeah, we observed
a strong down-regulation of
phosphorylation of ALK, which is dependent on mTOR pathway.
So we definitely want to look more at the
mTORC1/6K pathway. We also try to combine that
with rapamycin to inhibit the mTOR pathway,
and see if whether that can revert the cell death, but that was not
really feasible possible because rapamycin really
causes cell death, even at very low concentration.
So it was hard for me to test that. But we definitely want to look
at the PARP more in details too.
Thank you.
Just
one more question.
I think your model is really interesting.
I'm wondering if you can manipulate PDH kinase activity or the
entry of pyruvate into the mitochondria and alter responsiveness to
PKM2 activation to further credential the
conceptual model that you've painted.
Yeah. That's a really interesting point because,
actually,
we think some preliminary data show that what we see
is probably due to the accumulation of pyruvate into the mitochondria.
So by modulating PDH would be really interesting, and
also by tracing, we also observed an upregulation
of
M3 malate, which can suggest an upregulation
of PC, the pyruvate carboxylase. So we really want to look into more
details how pyruvate is getting into the mitochondria and then the consequences.
Definitely. It's interesting.
And relatedly, does HIF activation antagonize PKM2
activation?
Yeah.
Have you looked at that at all, or?
Okay.
That's really interesting to say.
Yeah.
Yeah. Then combining that with the activity.
And that can tell us more details about the mechanism, how it's
really happening.
Yeah.
So hopefully soon we can get more answers.
Great.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you all.
So we're
ending the talks a little bit early in the session.
I thought I'd take the opportunity to just summarize a couple of the themes that
emerged that link some of the talks that you've heard about
today.
One of the things that stood out is this increasing focus on
dietary therapies as a way to intervene and target cancer
metabolism. I think this is a really unique opportunity
that us in the cancer metabolism field have at our
disposal. It doesn't require the complex medicinal chemistry
campaigns that are required to generate new drugs to target
conventional protein targets, for example.
But nonetheless, this comes with some difficulties as well.
Thinking about formulation of diets, patient adherence to
those diets, tolerability,
the ability to modulate circulating metabolite abundance
simply by modifying
the consumption of particular metabolites.
SoIn just thinking about drawing a link
between some of these talks, we'd heard from Kahlil Abdullah about
some of the approaches applying a dietary therapy for an
inborn error of metabolism, now for brain tumor treatment.
There's a lot of excitement that is surrounding the ketogenic diet as
a treatment approach for cancer therapy.
This was highlighted very nicely in Omid's
presentation. But certainly, one of the challenges is
thinking about developing biomarkers that would allow
us to select for the optimal groups of patients that are
poised to respond to particular dietary interventions versus those that
may not.
With conventional targeted therapies, you have genomic sequencing data
that you can point to, coupling a kinase mutation, for
example, with the appropriate kinase inhibitor.
But analogs in the metabolism space are more difficult to come
by. And so I think as a field, we need to grapple with
how we'll incorporate biomarker-driven studies into the
evaluation of any promising new dietary
approaches for cancer treatment.
One other theme that I'll highlight before closing the session is just the
challenge in thinking about
the multifaceted role that mitochondrial metabolism plays in
supporting cancer progression, and at times
contributing to anti-tumor efficacy
of some promising therapies. We heard just recently from Dr.
DeTano about the way that you can essentially weaponize mitochondrial
metabolism through PKM2 activation
to try and stimulate ROS production and create tumor
cell-specific stress.
On the other hand, we've heard some exciting work from Sergio
Attanasio that highlighted the role of complex I inhibitor
development, and the ability to block ETC flux as another way
to target ROS stimulation and
elicit anti-tumor effects. So again, thinking about
context and trying to
build a conceptual model that accounts for both tumor cell intrinsic
and stromal effects of
therapies targeting mitochondrial metabolism will be paramount in
developing effective treatment strategies as continued
drug development towards intervening in mitochondrial
metabolism continues to mature.
So those were just a couple of the take-homes that I thought ran
throughout some of the talks in this session.
Just wanted to thank all our speakers for their contributions today.
Thank all of you for your attendance and for engagement.
And with that, we'll go ahead and close out the session. Thank you all.